before we start today I'd like to speak
directly to the families of the victims
who are here with us on behalf of myself
and the Boeing Company we are sorry
deeply and truly sorry as a husband and
father myself I'm heartbroken by your
losses
I think about you and your loved ones
every day and I know our entire Boeing
team does as well I know that probably
doesn't offer much comfort and healing
at this point but I want you to know
that we carry those memories with us
every day and every day that drives us
to improve the safety of our airplanes
and our industry and that will never
stop I'm grateful and humbled to be here
today and to be able to say these words
to the families directly and I want to
convey our absolute commitment to safety
our commitment to learning our
commitment to rebuilding the public's
confidence in what we do and to
preventing accidents from like this like
this from other ever happening again
panels the five-minute rule will be
observed strictly because we have
we've enhanced em casts in three ways
first it will now compare information
from both sensors instead of one before
activating second MKS will only activate
a single time and third M casts will
never provide more input than a pilot
can counteract using the control column
alone pilots will also continue to have
the ability to override M casts at any
time we've brought the best of Boeing to
this effort we spent over 100,000
engineering and test hours we've flown
more than 800 test flights we've
conducted simulator sessions with 545
participants from 99 customers and 41
global regulators I flown on a couple of
flights myself this is taken longer than
expected but we're committed to getting
it right leap over time as chairman of
this committee we've been challenged and
changed by these accidents we've made
mistakes and we got some things wrong
we're improving and we're learning and
we're continuing to learn they don't
want to have the same training for
co-pilots on the regional